in the storied sacred and altogether
absurdly sick esport that is
counter-strike there are certain
accomplishments that sit on every
enthusiast's
list feats that once fulfilled permit a
player to pronounce with a tone of
well-earned elitism i've made it whether
it's something subtle like getting added
by the official cs go twitter account or
something genuinely life-changing like
winning a major or hell even just seeing
your alias slapped onto a major sticker
counter-strike is filled with ways to
elevate and indeed immortalize oneself i
remember when the stickers got released
we was doing some press with big like
announcing a sponsor or something
and it was like 11 p.m walking back to
the hotel and i saw that they got
announced and i saw my stick in the
capture and i literally just started
crying instantly and i was like there's
no [ __ ] way it can happen i have a
[ __ ] sticker like impossible
i'm [ __ ] getting a bit
peery now man but of all the accolades
that can be bestowed upon those who live
to counter strikes none are as esteemed
or sought after as a montage cut by cs
go's mysterious meme loving frag movie
maestro
super sedum superstitum hello thank you
very much my friend hope you will do
more video about us
i would say spasticism
32 i agree with superstition what's up
super suit oh
best movie maker ever bro
good to have you here it's me man it's
me
superstition dearest counter-strike
stands the time has finally come for us
to evangelize the frog faced youtuber
whose balls to the wall edits serve as
aggressive in your face reminders of how
our favorite competitors and content
creators
really play csgo
[Music]
what started as a guy in a pepe mask
making frag movies in his spare time has
since evolved into one of cs go's
rowdiest most rambunctiously revered
shows of appreciation because
superstition isn't just memeing on his
chosen subjects
he's mythologizing them like stu is
jumping across the stairs before the
smoke popped and then what does he do he
catches sk members and then he was like
what's that [ __ ]
a small criminal strikes again
it was all an accident right like he
just was making good videos of good
players kind of turned into this like
validation almost like if you're a good
player you'll have a super cinema video
that's why i haven't got one yet so when
i become a good player i'll get one
super sedum you [ __ ] there's
just not there's nobody else like him
he's irreplaceable it's just how we put
the video together was so good
it's like you have a legit [ __ ]
talent for making that [ __ ] and you're
creative too dudes i'm gonna tell you
one more time
the best content creator
in csgo at the moment is super student
by far
so who
is super sedum how did he unwittingly
cement himself as counter-strike's
dankest chronicler and what exactly is
the criteria for getting oneself a
montage i don't know
let's ask him the most important thing i
have to want to do it you know my heart
has to be in it or else it's gonna be a
shitty ass video
[Music]
alright so before we dive into a video i
have been waiting literally years to
make i must ask that all of you lovely
counter-strike loving kings and queens
like the video subscribe to the channel
and turn on notifications
maybe if we get big enough we'll be
blessed with a how the score esports
really plays csgo
now in order to understand how
superstition became as
[ __ ] worshipped as he is today we
need to go all the way back to 2010 when
his channel saw its first upload and no
it wasn't source or 1.6 it was a modern
warfare 2 montage that he didn't even
cut i know not what you'd expect from a
danish cs die hard right i was the one
recording my gameplay and i sent it to a
friend i met over call of duty like a
dutch editor his name is serb 94 and he
he was the editor actually back then and
i just provided him footage the funny
thing is if you go back and watch that
montage you can actually see an early
glimpse of a lot of the things that
would later come to define superstitum's
style flashy color gradients quick and
dirty cuts and gunshots being mapped
onto grimy bass beats
xx420 no scope edits such as these were
actually deeply influential for super
sedum my biggest influencer was actually
tapes i really looked up to him because
he was from sweden so i tried to emulate
him be like edgy and funny like him but
i didn't really you know you can never
be like someone else you end up being a
cheap copy or just whatever you are
yourself superstition did eventually try
his own hand at editing of course and
was able to find success
but not in the way he'd anticipated i
tried to edit myself but it ended up
becoming commentary videos where
machinima respawn actually ended up
picking me up like i just wrote them a
message on youtube and they were like
yeah we can i was like what and then it
just blew up like that
we're taking the lead unfortunately it
was right around the time that super
sedum's edits were starting to b fire
that they gave way to an actual fire
which kind of forced him to take an
unplanned hiatus i bought my first
hotbuck hd pvr recorder but the thing
that happened i plugged in the wrong
cable and i could smell that it was
burned up like i spent all my money just
to get that and after that i was like
man it just threw me off and i kind of
gave up it wasn't until about six years
later when superstition was undertaking
his bachelor's degree that his love for
editing could finally be rekindled i
bought a macbook for the university we
started playing matchmaking
i started recording it with the
shadowplay and i started doing mm live
videos i called it the mm life the
matchmaking life
i throw flash in your eye
now superstition had been playing
counter-strike since he was a kid i mean
he did grow up in denmark after all
where they pretty much stick you on dust
2 straight out of the womb so the
franchise had always been in his blood i
mean my big brother always took me to
like cafes where you could play we
always went played cs like everybody
played like it was land there so
everybody played on that cafe server so
we played there i played at home i
didn't have a good pc so sometimes i
could play sometimes i could i couldn't
unfortunately the viewership on his mlm
life videos
wasn't exactly blowing down mid-doors
aside from just wanting to express
himself creatively super sedum really
wanted to capture the attention of the
cs go community he just didn't know how
i was like what the hell can i do to
make something special and at that point
i was like watching shocks a lot where
he was dancing in his streams and i was
like wouldn't it be fun to take his
camera put it on top of the original
player and he's just dancing and he's
just clapping everyone upset at this
point it is going to be shocks going for
the entry on the b side and drop down
he's got that flash they have no idea
devil's down that idea such a simple
idea just became like so huge it blew up
on reddit and people liked it and after
that i felt like i got something here
you know they're better side it's their
t-side where they really struggle
scream
is this real
he's gonna go for the follow-up but
after that there's almost no topping
within no time superstition's giddy
gimmicky little edits began to not only
evolve but take off from get right lurks
to sneaky beeky mollies to sneaky beaky
smokes to well sneaky beaky everything
like all of us the dude loved scream
super sedum had finally made it i really
got excited i was really happy like even
when i got like five thousand ten
thousand subs i was just every time i
got like ten thousand fifteen thousand i
screenshotted it and sent it to like my
close friends super sedum had finally
captured the attention of the cs go
community which was important because as
it turned out
our boy actually had something to say i
remember smith's back in the day i felt
so bad for him because the community was
kinda against him and i made a video
about him showcasing his highlights the
best of him and i think that's where i
ended up evolving to highlight videos
and montage videos where i showcased the
best of smith's like look guys he's
actually a decent player there's just so
much that people don't understand when
it comes to the pro scene like it's so
easy to judge but i just want to say
from the bottom of my heart that i
apologize for absolutely nothing smith i
shut the [ __ ] up but it wasn't until a
certain bullish bullied superstar to be
who the community had also been [ __ ]
on caught wind of super stim smith's
video that things really began to take
off i saw simple react to the smith's
video and he was also defending smith's
and i also knew just watching simple you
know i could see a lot of people hating
on him it's so easy to just blatantly
hate like anyone can see that this guy
doesn't know english properly and i just
know he couldn't like say what he wanted
to say and sometimes it came out very
directly and people were offended by it
what are you doing you [ __ ] idiots
let's go together and win or i'm gonna
leave
but what i saw was just basically why
the [ __ ] all these guys talking [ __ ]
he's destroying everyone in na and in eu
and yeah he was toxic back then but the
crazy thing about him is that you could
definitely see him growing up as a
person and that kids is how the first
real superstition montage came to be
the classic
seminal cut that is simple
the undertaker my dad loves wrestling
and that undertaker theme just fitted so
well with him because he is the guy who
goes into a server and just destroys
everyone claps everyone like he's just
so [ __ ] good you know and it just fit
perfectly with him
today he does that imagine by splicing
together simple's unearthly plays oft
memed expletives and the slew of [ __ ]
talk he'd received and layering it on
top of this world famous wrestling theme
superstition was able to fashion more
than just a frag movie he was able to
fashion something of a biopic i saw a
comet once who said superstition is so
good at creating a like a little story
in these videos instead of just a frag
movie because personally i hate frag
movies i have nothing like against them
i just think they're so like a
cinematics camera going here and there
showing the player in third person
getting the 5k like personally who cares
right you want something else at least i
do it might sound a little crazy but
super stim wasn't just making fun he was
crafting a sort of
myth he was taking players and turning
them into personas crafting caricatures
that thanks to superstitum's own
ingenuity came to boast some pretty
legendary epithets i saw that video with
stewie you know in the beginning of the
video where he's in a fight again i felt
so bad you know so i was like can i turn
this into something where it looks like
he's the one winning the dude who made
that funny video on screen made one of
2k today i think you're going to jet
i'll look oh my god he's stewie
stewie
when i was sitting there and uploading
the video i was like 2k song smooth
criminal smoke criminal i was like yeah
okay
so that name came up in like 15 seconds
and then it just blew up stew is jumping
across the stairs before the smoke
popped and then what does he do he
catches sk members with grenades in
their hands because they're about to
smoke or molly palace and then steve was
like what's that [ __ ] or whatever
the smoke criminal strikes again i was
watching all the tournaments and when
they said simple the undertaker or the
smoke criminal or whoever said it right
i'm like oh [ __ ] i i put my mark on the
cs go pro community you know super sedum
had become a hot commodity and before
long
everybody wanted a montage catch you
guys uh yeah
[Music]
yeah
super soon i'm just [ __ ] bro super
saiyan's in here you're making all my
[ __ ] make me a video
we ha
not on it not pushy
[Music]
from this point on having one of super
sedums coveted cuts branded around you
wasn't just a point of pride
it was a point of prestige yeah i think
he definitely kind of made it um i think
super saiyan's great i think he makes
awesome videos he
he just brings a community together and
his videos
attract other people and i feel like
with the cs community that's hard to
that's hard to do
one for him two three and four stewie if
you're patrick then who is that
crisp clean lock boys kill so far and
okay now problem safer
it didn't matter if you were a streamer
a solo carrying superstar had secured
yourself a slew of tournament wins or
emerged triumphant from a major it
didn't feel real like it had been
christened until you got the edit he
knew when the right time was to be like
this is the video like this is what
people want to see and that's good that
he doesn't like let people tell him what
to do right because that's as soon as
you start messing with that you're just
messing with somebody's like creative
mojo and then you just get a worse
product it's almost like a trophy like a
badge in itself this has got the
superstition like stamp i have to ask
derek what was better winning a major or
getting a super
of course what really sets super sedum
apart
was the way he chronicled his esport
superstition was
is
a bonafide auteur for starters his
videos were dripping in style from the
always perfect licensed track to that
lo-fi high-intensity grungy bullet to
the beat style he'd pioneered a super
sedum cut could always be spotted a mile
away there's not many people that do his
style videos and as
trolley or mimi
in a weird way shitty but also amazing
uh
there's just no there's nobody else like
him he's irreplaceable
but in addition to boasting the
abilities of an artist he also boasted
the attitude or dare i say ethos of one
at first i didn't make any money i still
don't make any ad revenue on my channel
because of songs but that's a choice i
made because i want the best songs
because the songs elevate the videos so
much without a great song the video
falls apart today superstitum stands as
counter-strike's sickest and most
unsuspecting king maker
but he also stands as its most secretive
who is superstitive you ask
we don't know and there's a good chance
we'll never know which is both exactly
how he likes it
and precisely the point he's very smart
the way he's marketing himself he's
never showed his face he's just this
frog guy that always does these sick
videos and it's like
to be interesting you have to have
something hidden you know like that's
always like a general uh generic rule of
marketing where wrestlers do it all the
time you'll never you have like the heel
and the good guy and then you'd never
give too much away and this sort of
stuff like it's smashed it honestly
it's just i don't know it's just a
basement there's not much you can say
about him you just have to watch his
videos and you'll come back and you'll
have the same opinion as me like he's
just insane
he's just a beast at the end of the day
my videos are not about me you know it's
about the players it's about the teams
it's about taking a player showcasing
their best side in terms of me i'm very
introverted so i honestly don't care
about getting likes or people liking me
like whenever i make a video and i look
at it and i see like yeah i'm happy with
this one that's enough for me and if
people like it that's just a bonus you
know
amen is me
superstatum
bonafide
bonafide bonafide okay i i get [ __ ]
with it because i learned to say the
phrase bonafide when i was learning
latin i always want to say a bona fide
and miles is like no
absolutely not no absolutely not i'm
like dude i literally like
a bona fide okay